[Music]
despite all the self-improvement content
that exists on YouTube or online in
general most people already know exactly
what they need to do to improve their
lives pretty much every day we have at
least one thing that we know we need to
do and if we were somehow able to just
sit down and do that thing from start to
finish our life would be better because
of it you know if you're a student maybe
that sitting down to write a couple
hundred words of that giant essay that
you need to write or maybe if you're
just a regular guy and you drive a 2005
Honda Civic maybe it's making weird
noises and you really should bring it
into the shop but for some reason you're
not because it's working now so you
assume it's gonna keep on working but
you really should get a checked out it's
not that people don't know what to do
that's not the problem
the problem is that people just don't do
those things they put it off they
distract themselves they do pretty much
anything under the Sun even stuff that
is sort of vaguely important in some way
but it's not really important to you you
might use that as a justification like
oh I'm sweeping the floor and that's
productive and you use that as an excuse
to not write the essay even though the
essay is the most important thing that
you should be doing and I don't want to
sound like a boomer or anything like
that but I actually think this is
becoming a bigger problem that more and
more people are facing as time goes on
and that's because distracting ourselves
is easier than it ever has been every
year companies spend billions upon
billions of dollars to shove ads or
products into your face with online
marketing that nobody wanted or asked
for you're just bombarded and assaulted
with all these little pop-ups scattering
your attention and distracting you from
whatever you are planning on doing when
you sat on the computer or opened your
phone or whatever anyways I'll spare you
all this woke talk and just cut to the
chase a world of distraction
simultaneously creates a huge demand for
people who can resist its draw or in
other words the rarest and most
important skill you can cultivate in
today's information age is the ability
to concentrate the ability to actively
concentrate on one thing for long
periods of time without getting
distracted isn't just one solution for
succeeding in the digital age it's
the solution but maybe I'm not saying
anything new you probably already know
this it's not like some crazy original
idea that I've had that if you can just
focus on doing important things then
you're gonna get better at life but like
I said before not knowing what we need
to do isn't the problem it's the fact
that we just don't do it maybe you've
tried to concentrate for long periods of
time but you find it extremely almost
pessimistically difficult but that's
exactly why I'm making this video I'm
probably the most distractible person
you ever met
naturally I'm very scatterbrained if a
light turns on any other room I'm like a
moth I'm like oh what's that let's go
check it out in fact my mom will tell
you I'm the worst procrastinator she's
ever raised but somehow even I have
managed to find little shortcuts and
strategies and little hacks to convert
myself into a relatively productive
human being who can concentrate on
boring things for long periods of time
it's a skill that anybody can learn and
one of the crazy things I've noticed is
that you don't need to dive into like
eight hours of deep work in order to
make progress in your life the bar is
actually way lower than that if you
could dive in for one hour on the most
important thing on your to-do list for
the day
with a ruthless active concentration you
will make substantial progress in your
life and as you get used to putting in
that hour of focus you can upgrade that
to an hour and a half to two hours to
three hours and even then that's like
that's so much intense focus that you'll
skyrocket past your goals and start
living a life that you actually thought
you'd be living at this point in your
life let's be real so I'm going to break
this video down into three categories
step one is to properly craft your
physical environment
[Music]
you've probably heard it a million times
that if you have a messy room that
you're gonna have a messy mind and if
you just clean and organize your room
it's kind of like cleaning and
organizing your mind there's an amazing
truth to this even if you just look at
it from a practical perspective each
room should have a use and each physical
space where you dwell should reduce the
friction that's in the way of doing the
things that that room was intended to
help you do so for instance in my own
home office I have a video editing PC
it's where I do all my creative stuff
it's where I'm shooting this video
behind me whoops right there if I want
to help myself succeed and to
concentrate and not get distracted I
should clean my desk to be as minimal as
possible the only things on there should
help me accomplish my tasks that I've
been setting out to do this might sound
like a total sidetrack rabbit-hole I
promise it'll make sense in a second so
I bought one of these awesome little
wireless chargers for my phone I bought
it off Amazon it was sleek it was sexy
kind of fake wood and I figured hey this
would be a great addition to my desk I
can put my phone on there I can see when
I'm getting notifications and I'll never
run out of juice in my phone throughout
the day but if you think about it that's
a really stupid idea why do I need to be
notified when somebody's texting me or
somebody comments on something on the
Facebook page or something like that
I'm literally inviting more distraction
into my life and it's dumb so how did I
get around this well there's a little
shelf next to me this one and I just put
my wireless phone charger there behind
me so that when I'm video editing into a
flow state and it doesn't distract me
little fixes like this seem really small
and you might think oh Joey you're
making like a 15 minute video about
little dumb tricks like this yes believe
me when it comes to your focus it is
everything and this doesn't just apply
to the workspace too there are other
little ways that your environment
dictates the amount of focus that you
have so for instance if you usually keep
your phone on your nightstand next to
your bed then that's kind of dumb if
your plan for that room is to go to
sleep so I personally found that I was
spending way too much time on my phone
before
I went to sleep and is becoming a real
problem and it was affecting my sleep
and I couldn't get into a deep sleep so
I woke up in the morning feeling really
groggy all the time every single day so
what I did is I bought a cheap little
Google Nest mini and I leave my phone on
a charging station outside of my bedroom
and it's great every night I say okay
Google set an alarm for 8:00 a.m.
tomorrow at 8:00 a.m. said thank you
google good night good night Google all
right that's okay you don't need to say
it back so your bedroom is for sleeping
your office is for working your kitchen
is for cooking your private bowling
alley in your basement is for bowling
okay moving on to section two this is
all about designing your digital
environment just like your physical
environment it is integral that you
design your digital environment to also
promote focus you know I'm not Thomas
Frank but I do have a couple sleeves
sleeves up my trick I have a couple
tricks up my sleeve that helped me
helped me focus on stuff here's a bunch
of things that helped me focus online so
a lot of these are Chrome extensions I
think they're available for Firefox as
well so number one is to download news
feed Eradicator for facebook and what
this does is it replaces your Facebook
homepage with a motivational quote and
it gets rid of you scrolling everywhere
so if you actually do stumble on
facebook especially when you're working
all there really is to do is see if you
have any notifications or respond to
messages you won't get caught in the
trap of just like absorbing all this
meaningless hotel nightmares kitchen
nightmares is Hotel nightmares one
another awesome Chrome extension and I
think it's also for Firefox as well is
DF YouTube which stands for distraction
free YouTube shout out to my friend Alex
for showing me this one if you're like
me YouTube is probably the biggest time
suck of all but what DF YouTube does is
it eliminates the classic homepage so
you're not bombarded with all these huge
thumbnails of all these different
recommended videos it just wipes it
clean you know you
still get the training tab if you're
into that kind of thing I don't know who
would be probably just like Lele pons
and the late night hosts my favorite
part about it is it also keeps the
subscriptions tab so that the people
you're actually subscribed to show up
there another thing that it does is that
it actually eliminates the sidebar of
all these recommended videos so that
when you're watching the video of a
channel that you actually meant to watch
you're not sucked into watching another
channel and you know you go down the
rabbit hole
you're just intentionally watching what
you set out to watch another thing I did
this is a little bit more extreme but it
worked really well for me is that I
deleted social media apps off my phone
in general and when I want to use a
particular app I actually have to
physically type it in on Safari or
whatever okay
section number three this is all about
training your mind
[Music]
sorry that's probably a bit much the
first two sections were all about
eliminating little traps and attention
sucking succubus but this whole section
is all about developing a philosophy and
a mindset of intentionality and this is
one of the most important and powerful
mindsets you can adopt to promote
concentration you need to train your
mind to be more intentional with your
time and you might think I'm coming at
this from a hustle culture perspective
where every single ounce of your time
needs to be dedicated to working on your
craft or grinding or something like that
but that's actually I don't believe that
at all you know for instance I am a big
fan of video games I think video games
are a great way to take a breather and
escape and engage with either a work of
art or a multiplayer experience but my
point is if you're gonna play video
games play the crap out of video games
for like an hour or two after you've
already put in the tremendous amount of
focus on something else
you've been productive you put in your
time you were intentional with it so
that you can fully immerse yourself in a
video game with no guilt being present
and fully engaged with whatever you're
doing whether that's having fun having a
conversation with a friend whether it's
working on something extremely creative
and fulfilling I feel like this is the
key to a happy and fulfilling life
one of the best ways that you can
develop more intentionality in your life
in order to promote focus but also just
to have a more fulfilling life in
general is to create a schedule for your
day and the schedule shouldn't be seen
as something like the super ruthless
iron-fisted limiting concoction that you
trap and imprison yourself in to
fulfilling your schedule is your own you
can design your day in a way that is
fulfilling to you you know before you
design your schedule you can really ask
yourself what could I do day to day that
I would truly feel happy and fulfilled
with how much time would I dedicate to
working and be realistic with that how
much time should I to socializing and be
realistic if gaming is important to you
or something like that or
working out or whatever you have the
freedom to design your day in a way
that's most fulfilling to you but once
you do that be absolutely ruthless with
being engaged and intentional with every
single thing on your schedule
that way when you're working you get way
more work done because you're
concentrated when you're playing you
have a lot more fun because you're right
they're not guiltily playing because you
didn't actually do work and you
shouldn't actually be playing and to
develop focus specifically start off by
scheduling one hour of focus on a very
specific thing that you really need to
get done pretty much everyone can manage
one hour once they enter a flow state
you know try to break past that
20-minute mark so you can enter that
flow state and after a couple of weeks
of getting used to doing an hour of deep
focus ramped it up to an hour and a half
then to two hours maybe two and a half
hours three if it's you know if you're
really getting the hang of it I find
that three hours is sort of the point of
time that I'm the most productive and
after that it's sort of diminishing
returns and as you get better at
developing the skill of concentration
you'll find that you get stuff done a
lot quicker you know you only put three
hours into work and you're really
concentrated and you can get more done
in those three hours and you typically
did in your entire week if you have a
high intensity workout you can usually
spend that hour and a half you spend at
the gym checking your phone and taking
10-minute recipe for sets you can reduce
that time to like 45 minutes so
basically you free up all this time in
your day for something else and if
you're looking for another something
else then I'd highly recommend checking
out my boy Thomas Franks brand new class
on Skillshare all about developing
habits a big thank you to skill share
for sponsoring this video
skill share is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
projects to create and the support of
fellow creatives Skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth Skillshare
offers classes designed for real life so
you can move your creative journey
forward without putting your life on
hold you can learn and grow with short
classes that fit your busy schedule
Thomas Frank's first class his
productivity master class
fits the digital environment topic of
today's video quite well so I'd also
highly recommend checking out that one
as well and the awesome thing is all
these classes I'm talking about and then
I'm recommending you can check out today
for free if you click the link of the
description it gives you two months of
Skillshare premium absolutely free and
after that it's still extremely
affordable if you pay for the annual
membership it comes in at less than $10
a month so once again click the link in
the description to get two months of
Skillshare premium absolutely free and
explore your creativity if you like this
video make sure to hit like because when
you hit like the algorithm blesses me
and it shoves this video in front of
other people's faces helping them out
and it also helps me out so it's a
complete win-win for everybody involved
if you like videos like this in general
definitely hit subscribe and hit the
bell icons so that you don't miss future
videos that I put out
I actually just created a second channel
so I'm gonna put the link in the
description for that as well I want to
upload more regularly but a usual better
ideas video definitely takes a lot of
time and effort so it's not like I can
be posting these every single day even
though I want to be so that's why I
created a second channel for more
off-the-cuff Mimi stuff well you know do
live streams maybe I'll start a podcast
on there click the link in the
description to subscribe to the second
channel and I think it will be actually
I know I know it'll be an awesome time
but anyways that is all for today I'm
really excited about the next video so
yeah we'll see you in that one later
you